now that things are opening up i was out
with a bunch of people there they said
let's go someplace expensive so i took
them to a chevron station
that's the thing we
we can finally leave the house and we
can't afford to drive anywhere
no i was putting the nozzle in my car
the other day it felt like i was taking
it up the ass i mean
i know
uh this
there is a there is a gas station in
mendocino county here in california
charging 8.45 for a gallon of gasoline
for that money they should check your
oil and your prostate
that's
but
of course part of it is because we cut
off the oil from russia which we had to
do because that terrible war in ukraine
we as people say we are all ukrainians
now and by that i mean we're also armed
with the teeth and our english ain't too
good
uh but
but
i
we
americans when they go all in on
something
like now everything russian is bad
everything i mean we are boycotting
every russian vodka pour that [ __ ] down
the drain
wouldn't it be better if we used it up i
don't know
the crew uh
yeah uh you know russian dressing
can't have that
uh
don't even think about playing that game
where you take a revolver and put one
bullet in it and
no that's
it's
don't
don't call it that you're going to do
what it's called a night out with
nicolas cage
these are scary times because you know
the more we put putin in the corner god
knows what he'll do i mean what freaks
me out is every time i see a picture of
vladimir putin he's sitting by himself
at the end of a ridiculously long table
all by himself he's like a cross between
ivan the terrible and howie mandel
and
you know
we don't want to start world war three
right i mean we're
we're caught in the middle here we're
trying to help ukraine but do it you
know from the sidelines we're
we're like the gay best friend in a
romantic comedy that's american
you